[Music]
in not worth it news mmm submitted by
Joel Malian breakfast yeah that's a guy
you've been doing all day yeah yeah Oh
Jamal Ian oh your guy he's great we love
Joe right everybody try to read the room
[Laughter]
great a millionaire was sent to prison
after a man he hired to build secret
tunnels under his home died oh that's a
prison yeah a guy died no you probably
didn't have permits he was probably
trying to make a secret Batcave
yeah any part of it probably wasn't
regulation yeah yeah government's nosey
business is like why do they have to
know like well first of all if you hire
a contractor and they say they can do a
job they should be able to do the job
yes [ __ ] obviously on paper if
he was like I will do this job or I will
die and then he signs his name you're
good or unless he was like maybe what if
he was just like the butler you know he
was like don't get a shovel and start
digging a hole
cuz I need to make like I don't want
anybody to know about it then yeah he
should go to jail yeah what happened
guys name is Daniel he's 28 years old
he's a millionaire stock trader Wow yeah
he was sentenced to nine years in prison
because he was found guilty of
second-degree no no because you said you
were like you saying about the guy sighs
I want to see the picture of it okay how
bad have to look it's great your yip-yap
in good can I do it could you show the
crowd something it does you can see be
straight on yeah but I miss like you
know see like
see beside you see guys do you see that
I could see it okay what happened all
right so this guy he was found guilty of
second-degree murder and involuntary
manslaughter because of this guy that he
hired to dig underground tunnels because
he was trying to be like protect himself
from North Korean missiles it's crazy
crazy yeah so this guy who's 21 years
old Ischia it was his name so this is
Daniel ooh
Ukrainian just a rich guy okay this is a
guy that died oh great so you there's no
information about how that how it all
came about like how like what was the
plan like yeah so I'm not sure what's
the relationship and just that one guy
digging holes yeah yeah he digged alive
wanted to keep it a secret there was a
hole in the floor that talked about 20
feet down and fanned out into tunnels
spending about 200 feet oh cool actually
and one died though I know yeah why
didn't have a team of people well you
didn't want to want the secret to get
out gonna have to kill like eight people
I know about your secret tunnels you
think he probably killed him so what
happened was that this home he saw he's
been this millionaire duties being
described as a type of hoarder by the
way this takes place in the suburban
Washington DC oh okay they don't even
have that much space for him to be
digging time they do underground so he
was kind of a hoarder so there were a
lot of like very unsafe electrical
wiring happening like cables and stuff
and and so because of that there was
this fire that broke out in the home and
this guy s Kia he was found naked and
charred in the burnt out basement Jesus
was in a Maryland resident which
happened in there stop drop and roll
thing like trying to get the fire off
still got baby it was maybe maybe he's
suffocated from the smoke you know I
mean in you know what I'm saying so
there was a fire and it takes all the
oxygen the first thing is supposed to do
is pee on yourself it prevents the fire
from burning this is what you did and no
this is uh this we learn and I won one
school nine one one school welcome to
nine one one school new instructor this
is nine one one school yeah so this dude
the millionaire guy Hugh would
blindfolds this guy what he said that
they were going to a home in Virginia so
he would have no that was on some secret
[ __ ]
I'm trying to make a Batcave yeah so but
so the dad of the victim he's just
saying like you know what it sucks
because he after four years if he's on
good behavior you could be eligible for
parole she was like it's not really like
justice for my son but at least he's
getting something well because but I
mean he did home seems like it was a
accident doesn't look like a
millionaire's home yeah million dollars
isn't what it was in DC - probably yeah
yeah well they didn't see his home was a
million dollars I said he was a
millionaire so he could have been
spending the money on digging tunnels
instead of buying like we probably
didn't have like a million like it was
like - yeah it's more than a bank or
something probably just was worth the
man's net worth how can you be smart
enough to be a stock whatever trader or
whatever but then you don't realize that
the city has so many like layers of like
you know the utility system and the
power lines a genius in different ways
some people are good at some [ __ ] and
they're just horrible at others you know
ever man exactly but I just don't get
how he like who was I just want to know
what their relationship was or the IRA
members I hate I had this job for you
I'm a pay you
obviously he was paying this guy a lot
of money he made just a bad choice if I
were the millionaire and I was looking
for someone to do some secret [ __ ] for
me I think I would start him off as like
my assistant right and then I would kind
of like ease them in like all right like
I'd probably do one little shitty thing
and see if he like does it for me and if
he does do that sheet of [ __ ] I'm like
oh what other sheet is sure what this
guy do I would go I would have just went
down the Home Depot legal anyways yeah
that's all on you right this way I'm
just saying no B he's a either you're
gonna pay him a lot of money yeah but
you could you worried about secrecy so
I'm saying that you get those guys you
can start digging a hole to Mexico tell
Alyssa for life you look it they're all
some of the ninjas are farm Depot
they're already legal ninja you know the
Home Depot goes dude they have a lot
illegal ninja stuff oh yeah that's my
bad I thought it yeah I was talking
about the ninja to Mexico because I
wanna check it out cuz you know what
Cancun's pretty tight well sounds like
an awesome plan yeah oh yeah so it's
just like the fact that this millionaire
was so paranoid he had to hire this one
21 year old and by the way I mentioned
he was 28 right he was really young wait
who's 28 28 was a millionaire 21 is a
victim and so yeah like the fact that
huge did they say how they met I don't
want to look a mess
oh yeah what's the question for the same
answer I want to know is you know how
grief I was in a Craigslist ad is he
saying he blindfolded you dig a hole
[ __ ] how much mud was there money
exchange
how do we know that he didn't just
kidnap if you get hired and somebody's
like I can't want to blindfold you what
you could do would like that but if you
give here if you get hired and they guys
like here's a shovel I started off that
way though is what I'm saying see that
everybody sneaky like you don't work for
her she's got like five bodies under her
yeah we just got a new house there no
bodies on that one you moved almost
slips up digging in parties yeah I don't
know how they met and I don't know like
what the deal was I just know that this
this guy died why is he in trouble why
is a millionaire because of the unsafety
like the fact that it was so unsafe the
conditions where there were so many pals
of garbage bother started items all
throughout the home yeah mr. Blaine and
there was like narrow maze like pathways
like unsafe work conditions care oh wow
so because of that like you see what da
she should with the HR I'm sorry
so they're saying that that's the victim
he he smelled something smoky he sent a
text message about it to the millionaire
and then the millionaire hear what he
was allowed to have his phone
yeah and hit reception underground
blindfolded then thank you gonna drop he
gonna drop the pin very smart
this should be a workout it's real done
the wrong person died next year he
texted and the millionaire didn't
realize the other phones I can't smoke
this fool oh yeah true yes probably
against regulations
yeah so that's when he flipped a circuit
breaker and that's when the fire broke
out is the hue they're saying that the
millionaire tried to rescue the victim
but he couldn't because of the smoke
that's why I'm saying he probably didn't
die from fire he died from smoke you
know we probably suffocated why was he
naked yeah make it in charges how he was
found oh he was he was charred also yeah
yeah that's a [ __ ] up way to go that's
a terrible way to go oh the the 21 year
old was naked and charred yeah I thought
the millionaire was felony millionaires
going to prison
I know but I thought when the cops found
him he was charred and inhaler and then
they locked him up be a negative chart
on my own time thought he peed on
himself so the fired you nobody peed on
himself you wanna be that's another
video oh that's so sad I know it sound
like there was foul play because the dad
of the victim was like what's that foul
play it's just stupid
yeah oh yeah right we saw how their sole
king crab fisherman cuz that's telling a
dangerous job yeah like how they have
like dangerous jobs then it's like no
one's allowed to work them no no because
you have like nature to that cause it's
regulated maybe they also have me sign
waivers and stuff like that cuz for the
crab man it's just you can't predict
mother nature but they're just saying
like mother nature's [ __ ] could take
your life yeah okay well sign up for
that and never probably compensated her
buyers made by nature yeah but this is
fun this one no this was that guy's
fault
like unpermitted unpermitted
construction or whatever like the whole
thing was a little that makes sense yeah
cuz unregular I guess it's the
regulation answer my own question yeah
there you go king crab one is regulated
got it we helped you we hoped you know I
got some credit to Nick nah
[Music]
[Music]